to say that the environment secretary
george eustis uh joins us on the program
mr eustis great to have you on and uh
thank you so much for for braving the
cold i know exactly how cold it is uh
just outside the office this morning so
let's get rattling on as you just heard
we're we're running a series of special
programs at this juncture in our
response to covid19 to to assess where
where things have gone wrong and perhaps
some of the lessons learned i wonder if
you might identify one area in which we
we have as a as a country changed our
response
one mistake that we made and have
learned from
well look it's been an emerging
situation and evidence has developed as
time has gone on and of course we've
changed our approach in some areas so
initially the advice was that uh there
wasn't a great deal of value in wearing
face masks
as the evidence emerged the world health
organization changed that view and we
changed
our advice in line with that so
yes this has been a dynamic evolving
situation the government's you know
responded to that and changed its
position in some areas for instance face
um
masks
i wonder then if we might dwell just
briefly it is away from your brief but
on on universal credit then there is a
real pressure um from recipients of the
the 20-pound uplift to politicians on
your side of the the chamber of the
house of commons
is there any possibility that you know
in the immediate future we might get a
decision as to whether or not that that
20 pound uplift might last substantially
longer perhaps as long as a year
well look obviously it's got a few more
months uh to run i think a couple more
months to run and um rishi sunak i'm
sure when he does his budget we'll be
looking at all these issues carefully we
do know that uh you know it's affected
household incomes and the resilience of
households this uh lockdown and the
pandemic generally we know and we put in
place measures to help some of the most
vulnerable afford food because there's
been some issues with families unable to
afford food we've put new measures in to
support them and we've had this
temporary uplift in the universal credit
at some point we need to get back to
normal get people back uh working again
earning full salaries again that's got
to be
the route to recovery but i'm sure that
uh as we emerge from the lockdown you
know rishi sunak will be looking
carefully at the types of measures that
will be needed uh to make that
transition from lockdown back to life as
normal
um well let's talk about the variants
that are currently in the country at the
moment and clearly there has been a
degree of concern about about the south
african variant particularly because of
fears around the efficacy of various uh
vaccines i i wonder if you might kind of
reiterate the points made by jonathan
van tam at yesterday's news conference
that look you know we have to be mindful
we have to be concerned about these new
variants but the one which we are
dealing with in the united kingdom well
the vaccines do pretty well with that
yes and that remains uh our main
challenge the moment is dealing with a
so-called kent variant which is uh
highly infectious spreads more quickly
than some of the other variants
and dominates at the moment and is our
primary challenge and the vaccines are
fully efficacious against that
particular strain but we constantly
monitor other variants around the world
there is always a risk that there will
be a variant that manages to to
circumvent uh the vaccines that we have
and that's why we have to constantly
redouble our efforts to evolve the
vaccine so that they can deal with any
new variants that might arrive but also
why we are you know constantly looking
and toughening our approach to
quarantine for those arriving from
overseas because until we have an
ability to to vary the vaccine and
update the vaccine to meet those new
challenges we do have to exercise some
caution about international travel and
that's why we put in place the measures
we have
sure but just in terms of the south
african variant
the case is numbered less than a couple
of hundred at the moment according to to
jonathan van tan but but given that
there is an eight-day process for us to
be able to sequence uh sequence an
individual case and discover whether
it's the south african uh variant given
the fact that we understand that
community transmission is taken has has
taken place
it is by no means beyond possibility
that we could see a surge in the south
african variant isn't it
well that we we can't be complacent but
i think what professor van tam said
yesterday is that the evidence so far
suggests that the south african variant
is actually less contagious than the
kent one so it travels at a at a lower
speed it hasn't got that uh that highly
uh infectious rate that we see in the
kent uh variant it's here in very small
numbers now so we have to obviously
monitor it very closely but it's also
the case that while there had been
concerns uh that some of the vaccines
yesterday vaccine might not be fully
effective against the south african
variant you know those concerns have
also receded somewhat in that you know
the the evidence seems to say that it it
prevents some of the most uh serious um
symptoms of the virus and therefore does
provide some protection
um once again minister i appear to be
learning from the papers that we're
going to be seeing some toughening up
around around our borders and you you
alluded to it a second ago is it the
case that we are now going to see
people who arrive here in the united
kingdom mandatory testing day two day
after their arrival
well look i i don't think a final
decision has been made on that but we do
keep all of this under review we've
stopped short of having a sort of total
closure of the border at this stage
we actually think that
it causes a lot of disruption but
doesn't add a huge amount whereas the
measures we have put in place already we
require a pre-travel test
and the carriers are required to check
that test before passengers board we
require everybody to quarantine for a
period when they arrive here and as you
know we've introduced new measures to
ensure that those coming from high-risk
countries will quarantine in hotels in
future there is a there is a case for
doing some
testing during quarantine we already
have a provision to so that they can
test to release from quarantine earlier
and we're obviously looking at this to
see whether we can strengthen these
measures further
if a decision has not yet been made why
once again am i learning about something
in the newspapers why once again has
briefing been made presumably by someone
relatively senior in the civil service
or relatively senior in government
and the papers are once again
speculating about it
well look i as you uh as you know neil i
was once a press secretary and you we
often end up reading things in the
papers that we would prefer not to um
that the reason i can only uh presume
that it has appeared in the papers is
that it is a subject that's being
discussed at the moment within
government i don't think a final
decision has been made but i understand
um you know matt hancock may be looking
at this further today
and obviously if a decision is made then
he'll make an announcement at that point
but um you know for now we've got in
place the measures we have we're
constantly looking at refining things we
don't rule out uh things like um
post quarantine or during quarantine
testing we already have it for people to
release from quarantine early but you
know i don't want to pre-judge anything
matt hancock might say
sure but but on another and particularly
related topic quarantine hotels we did
have the announcement that those would
be introduced at some point we had an
announcement that there would be an
announcement we still do not yet know
when that announcement is going to be
what we do learn from the papers this
morning is that perhaps one of the
reasons why we haven't been able to move
forward with that is that the government
hasn't been able to book a hotel room
well look i know that the department for
health are working on this working with
some of the hotel operators they're in
discussion about
procuring those hotel rooms
we've got a policy in place that from
the 15th of february that's next monday
people coming from those high-risk
countries we'll have to quarantine in
hotels i'm confident that we will have
that uh provision in place and i'm aware
that discussions are ongoing at the
moment
have we booked any hotels though because
the the strong implication in what
indeed the story in the papers this
morning is that we haven't booked them
we haven't been to any
well my understanding is and this is
obviously a procurement issue that
officials in the department of health
are dealing with my understanding is
that they are in discussion with
operators uh those discussions have not
yet concluded but they're confident that
they will conclude in good time for the
quarantine policy to start on the 15th
of february as planned
can i just talk briefly about vaccine
passports we heard from from the deans
of hawaii that vaccine passports not
something that the government is going
to be doing i just wonder what the
government's position is on companies
private publicly traded companies
insisting on people who access their
services demonstrating that they have
had a vaccine let's say restaurants
let's say pubs what would be the
government's position on that
well i think it'll hopefully be
unnecessary in the sense that
within the next week or so we hope to
have vaccinated all uh of the uh most
vulnerable cohorts all of the over 70s
were already um well on the way there
with i think over 90 percent of the over
75s now vaccinated and the reality is
that as we start to you know emerge from
lockdown when that moment comes and the
prime minister will be outlining that uh
that journey on the 22nd of february by
the time we start to loosen that lock
down then we we will have vaccinated all
of those most vulnerable cohorts and
therefore you know the risk recedes and
it probably wouldn't be worth a while of
any individual business trying to check
whether people have been vaccinated so
our approach to vaccination is to
vaccinate the most vulnerable cohorts in
order and to to roll out the vaccine as
quickly as possible i very very much
doubt that it'll be worth anybody's
while checking whether someone's been
vaccinated simply because i say many of
the most vulnerable will have been by
the time we get to easing lockdown
sure what what then of of within the
health services
itself the royal college of nursing has
released data that says that you know 15
of nurses remain unvaccinated and that
is for for a variety of reasons uh but
of those who remain unvaccinated sorry
of those nurses that they pulled four
percent had decided not to take the
vaccine can we conceive of circumstances
in which we would not insist on
frontline healthcare professionals
having the vaccine if they had been
offered it
well look i think it's always very
difficult to
require or mandate vaccination in that
way
it's always been the case that uh people
have to choose to to want it obviously
it's disappointing if there's people in
uh you know working in our nhs who
themselves in small very small numbers
have decided not to have the vaccine
we want to get maximum protection
particularly for those vulnerable
cohorts but also for those such as those
working in the nhs who are particularly
exposed and the vast majority of them
have taken up the vaccine